おっ
8自分は田中賢治といいましてえっと仕事は宴試合をしています
でインジアっていうのは発見いろんなことを白金しなければいけないということでその
発見の一つで結構マメ知識みたいなことを
をちょっと入った6ところを少しお話したいと思います
でこの中で指パッチ皆さんあのあまあしてるんですけど指パッチできる人
八木は確かですねこれできる方法を教えます
で
まずどんなんて立ってるかっていうところを話したいと思います
遊パチ普通高校ですね中指と親指を破って鳴らすんですけども
結構なるんですけど自分ですでこれなんて立ってるかっていうのを説明します
で重要なのはこれ薬指薬指がこの
親指の腹ここに必ず当たるようにしてください
で
それから中指をこの親指の腹っとなって薬指のかにここにあたりをしてください
そうするとなります
なりやすくなりますでちょっとあのか乾燥している肌
かあの油ちょっとあの方々してるってだとなりにくいんですけども
この他にに落とすっていうような動きをすると必ずなるようになっています
いろいろ2ねえこれなんであのう
そこを発見したかというとやっぱりエンジニアですねあの
なぜこうなりますなんてなるのかなっていうのをずーっとこう指見ながら考えましたね
そういうときにじゃあ話してじゃあこないときにどうするかあったら雨ならないんで
ピチットはなりますけどもいいよとなりませんねっていう
じゃあよくよく見るとここに中に入って来ないっていう
で中指でもあっちょっとずれるとダメだねっていう
そういうこの八景観察と
じゃあなんでなんでっていうところを繰り返しをすることによって
これのが本当に一番なるパターンっていうのを発見する
これというのはあのエンジェル必要でどういった現象を置きているかっていうのを正確
に把握してその原因っていうまあ多分これ本当に分析すると個々の音がこういう動きを
するから音として発するんだなっていうのになると思いまーそこまで行ってないです
けど
もうそういったところをイメージするのが非常に重要だなというところで
ただ日常生活でもまぁ今回のテーマの of the box にもあるんですけども
何でもこう何気ないなんでなのかなーなるからなる店でなくて
じゃあなんでなるんだなっていうところいろいろ見ていくと新しい発見っていうのを
が起こるんだなっていうのがちょっと自分の部屋になります
なので皆さんもいろんなことに興味を持って何気ないことでもなんでだろーなんで
だろーっていうことを繰り返すことによって
以上の新しい発見をしていただければと思います
え
短い何ですか以上ですよありがとうございました